Resident Evil 4 remake is really more of
a reimagining of the 2005 classic while
it's certainly built on the DNA of the
original there's been a number of
additions and big old changes that make
this experience all its own so let's go
over some of those big changes including
some stuff that was totally cut as a
heads up the second half of this video
is going to be spoilery Galore so we'll
have a warning when that section comes
okay so let's kick it off with some of
the more broader changes to the gameplay
mechanics crafting while all of the
Resident Evil games have featured some
light crafting usually in the form of
combining herbs and sometimes different
kinds of gunpowder it still varies game
to game the original Resident Evil 4 for
example was primarily just combining
herbs Resident Evil 4 remake takes it a
smidge further but thankfully without
over complicating it crafting now
consists of just combining three things
gunpowder and small and large Resources
with each individual item craft
requiring just two ingredients whether
it's handgun ammo shotgun shells bolts
for your crossbow or grenades crafting
is thankfully simplified which keeps
things streamlined and doesn't bog down
the pacing in any way side quests this
time around you'll be doing more than
just hunting down blue medallions to
shoot requests have been expanded with a
lot more variety like Pest Control such
as hunting down rats vipers or even
larger terrifying foes churning in
request earns you gems that you can
trade for special items like weapon
upgrades treasure maps emeralds and more
this is a welcome shake up to the
original formula that gives you more
options to unlock things rather than
just grinding through playthroughs for
more money and make sure you read the
requests they're usually a quirky look
into the merchant that gives him a
little more extra color than in the
original
treasure treasure is vastly improved in
this game not only is there more of it
to find but the system in which you
inlay gems has been improved thanks to a
gemstone bonus list which gives more
flexibility to make a little more moolah
it serves as his own little mechanic
that's actually pretty fun and is way
more intuitive than the originals
hunting for Treasure is also just a bit
more involved as there's now locked
drawers throughout the world they
require finding small keys to open them
some of which involve their own little
mini puzzle speaking of puzzles this
game has plenty of them including new
takes on old ones Capcom has changed all
the puzzles keeping things fresh for
returning players who know the game
backwards and forwards while you'll find
a handful of puzzles through the main
story a lot of the new ones are used for
the aforementioned treasure hunting also
for returning players do you remember
that Dreadful Sliding Puzzle that Ashley
had to do well good news it is gone
instead there's a similar puzzle but it
no longer halts the progress of the
story and you'll likely solve it by
random like I did but I still loved it
new weapons all the weapons you know and
love from the original are still there
with the addition of a couple new ones
Leon can now Rock a crossbow similar to
Ada Wong's from the first one this bad
boy allows you to do some sneaking from
a distance or acts as a mine launcher
that'll send baddies flying there's also
an M16 like rifle called the cqbr
assault rifle that packs a punch and
shoots at a high rate but the trade-off
of sniper rifle ammo which can be seldom
so use accordingly another new one to
the mix is the le5 a take on the MP5 and
uses TMP ammo one thing that what's
great about the Remake is that you're no
longer forced to sell your guns and
instead they can be stored which is good
because these weapons allow for a lot of
great player expression and have their
own pros and cons in battle Additionally
the Remake introduces exclusive upgrades
for each weapon which will vastly
improve a specific functionality like
along the le5 to penetrate up to five
targets farm animals don't mess around
this is a small but satisfying touch
that really adds to the versatility of
re4rs world so now in stressful battles
animals will have no problem in joining
the fight resulting in things like this
where the pigs will just beat up
anything in their path and it's a
spectacle to behold also in my three
playthroughs of this game I actually
only witnessed this happen once which
makes this moment all the more special
to me alright spoiler time from this
moment on we're going to be spoiling the
structural parts of the game some major
changes to levels and some stuff that's
been entirely cut so this is it if you
don't want this stuff spoiled for you
this is your warning okay if you're
still here you've been warned the bell
tower this time around the bell tower
blows up creating a big old obstacle
around the village not only does it make
for an unexpected and cool set piece but
it's a welcome shift in a familiar
environment the cable car Gondola scene
the cable car scene has been entirely
cut from the Remake a part that required
the player to track around two areas to
find Keys preceding the original Mendez
fight instead the time you would have
usually spent roaming around this part
and shooting off enemies from a distance
has been filled out in other places most
notably in chapter 4 with the newly
expanded boat exploration following the
Del Lago fight where you'll be trudging
around similarly to finding two items
necessary to progress so it's just if
anything been remixed a bit and speaking
of remixes the castle now it feels much
more or like well a castle the castle
Vibes are strong this time around all
the way down to the torture dungeon
where you'll now face the gyarador to
the newly added castle maze puzzle
there's also the addition of a castle
giant which was not in the original at
all a newly added and memorable set
piece this in fact replaces the second
giant fight from the original game and
changes the formula completely for
returning players overall I think the
castle has been honed in and as a result
gets some good pacing treatment I think
this is most notable in the now reworked
grand hall section that'll have you
hunting down mythical statues to
progress this section is sort of like
its own mini Resident Evil mansion with
branching paths that you can do in any
order you'd like it's very
self-contained compared to the original
and adds a nice flow and feels more
natural in the context of the castle
Ashley's lone part the scene in which
you get to take full control of Ashley
has received a hefty facelift and it is
way more more terrifying and stressful
than before this time around you're not
just throwing lanterns at cultists but
instead fending off those terrifying
lost plagas occupied suits of armor with
a special lantern that freezes them in
their tracks but only temporarily the
scene has some extra puzzles thrown into
the mix too and nothing nearly as
annoying as that dim Sliding Puzzle the
true horror of this original scene good
riddance new enemies and new takes on
old ones the most iconic enemies are
back with the exception of one which
we'll get into later but now there's
even more including a remix of some old
ones some ganados for example don't die
immediately and have to be executed
before they rise back up as an erratic
more dangerous foe some New Heavies have
joined the fight too including the
bullheaded man who will twirl a giant
hammer knocking down enemies around him
to get you a remix on an old enemy are
the creepy crawly plaga that will now
now attach themselves to gonado and will
turn them even more rabid if you don't
shoot them quick they can make a
situation go Ari real quick speaking of
which the red rope cultists are more
than just a leader figure they now have
the power to summon the lost plagas to
erupt from Cultus heads instantly so
gunning him down ASAP makes for a white
knuckled anxiety attack of a fight the
minecart scene now in the original it
was already a romp but it has now been
turned up to 11 making it a full blowing
Thrill Ride which is only enhanced now
that Louise joins along the ride and of
course the very mention of luis's
presence of course means that he sticks
around a little longer in this game than
in the original you're now required to
control the cart and shoot at the same
time there's also just something
incredibly funny about seeing the
chainsaw wielding Dr Salvador riding at
a cart alongside you I laughed a lot
luis's fate that's right Luis still
meets his inevitable demise but now at
the hands of krauser this to me is a
welcome change as it gives Louise a lot
more screen time gives him a more
meaningful death and a little extra
motivation to hate krauser as a bad guy
albeit he is a little more fleshed out
and sympathetic this time around but
still an absolute total action movie
cornball so at least they kept that
right the clock tower it is back but
instead of running from a giant
mechanical Ramon Salazar one of the
probably more absurd set pieces from the
original they instead breathe fire which
is of course still ridiculous and can't
be in its own right so you know it's not
the same but you know at least he's
still there the Ramon Salazar fight
While most of the boss fights have
received a little oomph they generally
are the same as before with the
exception of salazars which is a far
more versatile fight that'll have you
running around an arena of multiple
floor collecting resources and dodging
an array of attacks before Salazar was
just a wall of flesh with a weak point
you just had to shoot over and over
again so this is a welcome change and
possibly up there as one of my favorite
fights in the remake Ramon's new design
as this monster whips and snaps around
the environment is just a whole lot more
inspiring to look at Ashley's forklift
scene and the original Ashley got the
chance to drive a giant forklift like
machine which resulted in a rather
unrails moment just shooting waves after
waves of enemies this time however she's
still putting her construction hat on
but taking control of a giant wrecking
ball as tries to break down a big old
wall it is up to you to defend her while
chaos ensues this is one of the more
tuned examples of grounding the design
more into the areas themselves than the
original instead of you know the first
one that took Leon and Ashley through an
elaborate industrial garbage facility
hidden underneath an island this one you
know as ridiculous as it is just makes a
little more sense the u3 fight
one of the most memorable and maybe
frustrating boss fights depending on who
you ask has been entirely removed this
might come as a bummer to some purists
but I personally always viewed it as one
of the more out of nowhere boss fights
that bogged down the latter half of the
game's pacing just know that for
everything that's been cut something has
indeed absolutely taken its place so
just keep that in mind the laser room
yes it's true the ludicrous completely
out of nowhere qte cool dude scene of
Leon doing gymnastics through a wall of
security lasers is gone again in the
context of this new game and how more
grounded things feel it makes sense that
they'd remove it but I can't help admit
you know to being just a little bummed
because you know that scene is
ridiculous and I love it at least you
know it still exists in the original but
so it goes alright this is the last one
and the biggest spoiler of them all so
this is it if you haven't finished the
game yet or just don't want this you
know and spoil for you in general stop
now Wesker that's right wesker's
involvement in residual 4 is now much
more overt which now shows him in a
mid-credit scene chatting up with Ada
Wong while this version of the Remake
did not launch with the additional Ada
content it's still too soon to say
whether or not it'll be returning as say
DLC we'll see nonetheless Wesker is
front and center this time around during
the ending so there you have it okay
thanks for watching and make sure to
check out all the other Resident Evil 4
remake content we got including our 10
out of 10 review of the game okay till
next time see you later